[Music]
the things I learned about resilience -
my time in prison is that human beings I
believe by nature are very resilient and
oftentimes we don't recognize our own
resiliency until we're faced with
obstacles and circumstances that
challenges us and pushes us and it looks
different for everybody you know when I
think about my journey through in prison
you know I went through some very
adverse experiences I had some
significant obstacles to overcome
including you know long-term solitary
confinement which they estimate is
designed to drive a person crazy after
90 days and what I found in that
environment is that people figure out
ways to cope and to survive and to get
through when they're forced to do so and
for me I found that I was very
resourceful when my back was against the
wall and that resilience was also a
choice you know I had a choice in
whether to give up I had two choice in
whether to fight for a second chance and
you know that type of resilience was
inspired by other people you know I read
Nelson Mandela's autobiography you know
I read the poem Invictus I've read you
know Malcolm X's autobiography no I
loved autobiographies but what I learned
through reading is that if you
acknowledge what you're going through
and you recognize that it is the
obstacle and that it's that dark moment
but you also realized there's light on
the other side of that tunnel then you
can get through and to me I think hope
it's probably the cornerstone of
resilience as long as you have hope you
can come out on the other side of
anything once you dim the light of hope
there's no possibility of you coming out
on the other side and to me I think
that's what resiliency is you know I
always looked at if I focus on the
purpose instead of the pain then I can
get through
the other side and that's how I live my
life and to me you know those things and
body what resilience really is three of
the ingredients toward being resilient
is you have to be optimistic optimism is
such an integral part of getting through
adversity I would say a second thing is
really being resourceful and figuring
out in your environment what are things
people or you know inspiring you know
components that you can utilize to help
you cope with whatever it is you're
going through and then I think the third
thing would would be you have to have
memory loss know that probably sounds
crazy right but what I found is that a
lot of times we replay memories that no
longer exist over and over in our head
and what that does is it holds you
hostage and so once you begin to release
those memories and recognize that you
can never reclaim that space or that
time or that experience then you can
move forward in life you know because
now you've taken the seconds off your
feet and you're a lot more mobile and I
think in order to be resilient you have
to not be thinking about what happened
in the past and you really just have to
be focused on what you need to do to
move forward
[Music]